now I'm Greg Gutfeld with judge Jeanine
Juan Williams Jesse Watters and she
carpools on a rumba Cantabria out of the
five
[Music]
we are exactly one year away from the
election in a moment we're gonna fill a
time capsule right here with items that
best symbolize this coming year will it
be a strand of Bernie's ear hair a Liz
Warren headdress or a Life Alert for
very slow sleepy Joe very slow sleepy
Joe now they haven't all freaked out
because he makes a mistake every time he
speaks oh I can just see these handlers
cuz their handlers like they use our
horses the handlers right all right get
him off now he's been up there long
enough so they're screaming get off get
off
sleepy Joe get off the stage please
please Joe you're doing fine that was
President Trump last night at a wild
rally in Kentucky talking about the
stuff that matters like the great Lou
Dobbs the great Lou Dobbs and he said
when Trump took over President Trump he
used to say Trump is a great president
then he said Trump is the greatest
president since Ronald Reagan so this
year's gonna be historical and
hysterical a two-way battle not just a
one-way street
just ask corrupt politicians Nancy
Pelosi and Adam Schiff corrupt
politicians Nancy Pelosi of Adam Schiff
they are corrupt
Nancy oughta stop wasting time go back
to her district in San Francisco help
the homeless get rid of the drugs get
rid of the needles that are lying all
over the street there you go so can we
already protect who might win the
impeachment gambits suggest stems know
if they stick to an election they're
gonna lose impeachment is the fire alarm
they pull to cancel school on the day of
the big test it's either that or move to
Canada even the new battleground state
polls look pretty good for Trump as the
media clings to his low favorability
polls that's because they still believe
America must adore who they vote for
nope they don't need a mr. nice guy
right Jorge no matter what your views
are on Trump as a president guys are bad
luck
money that he's made the obstacles that
he's conquista bad mother his own way
hmm Trump is an MMA politician in a cage
debate
he'll fish hook his opponents that's
unseemly but it's why he won in 2016 but
the best way to show you how good the
country is doing under Trump is to watch
what is the news has become now an
analysis on Trump's misspellings whether
he was booed or not an event or more
sweaty coverage of a phone call all
opinion problems about personality it
wasn't always like this in the past we
had body bags and detached
professionalism now we have no body bags
and a wild man
I prefer that trade-off in a year so
will a lot of people all right he's
already sick in his head
and this segment hasn't even started all
right so we have a we have a look at
these till he gets up so when they said
the great Lou Dobbs
because Gregg pointed out you know when
it's hysteria you know that's what we
got right so you can you can put it
right there where it is you know what
you get all right so this is the time
capsule that we purchased and we remove
the top look at that I'll put this
safely over here and this is the actual
time capsule so let's go around the
looks like something else I bought in
college but we won't get into that judge
what would you like to put into the time
capsule which will open next year when
the election is done what is it that's
it yeah why the yes you know what that
looks like well that looks like the
container in the pantry I have that you
put spaghetti and you put your daddy in
it new clothing every Sunday you open it
okay all right so this is my gavel
clearly it's not a glas gamble because
it didn't break its new sight but I
think it'll be time for justice I think
there's no question that when the next
election comes around it'll be time to
not worry about whether or not
indictments are political or not
political
it'll be about true justice and that's
why I'm putting my gavel in there cuz
I'm counting on justice nice all right
wine I'm not sure what that meant but I
know you're a backer you know what don't
lock him up yet no I got this judge I've
got the Constitution of the United
States and I'm hoping that in a year we
still have a constitutional form of
government that we don't have an
autocracy I hope that there is a proper
succession in line I hope that people
like a mutiny or something you know that
whoever wins can take office Democrats
are going to just stand by and say
congrats Donald when he wins again well
the Democrats are the ones who
acknowledged his victory last time fix
your narrative but it's not true Hillary
Clinton conceded the election and you
matter hang on remember it's donald
trump who said i'm not sure also judge
you gotta put it in this way or none of
things are gonna fit in this that's
better okay yes I was told to do that by
the way I did not think of that myself I
am gonna put in the capsule the polls
hmm as of right now that showed Donald
Trump losing to Warren to Bernie Sanders
and to Joe Biden by 15 points yes okay
and I just want to remind everybody the
same poll a year out before last
election had Hillary Clinton beating
Donald Trump by 12 points so when I
opened the capsule next election after a
year I don't think that'll term that
will have lost to any of these people by
15 points and that's why I will be
stuffing this thing in like so there
because I know Juan likes to cite polls
and that will be one poll that we will
be citing this will be a message in a
bottle and the message will be that you
were wrong yes yes so I'm not breaking
the rules here first of all there's
gonna be a lot of political ads like a
lot mm-hmm
so I got earplugs very
she wants CBS brand I have also probably
the best predictor holes but it's
today's stock market highest ever right
I don't know yesterday's was I don't
know the top of Kabuto sorry
Dow Jones Nasdaq and SP 500 records okay
so I'm gonna put this in the capsule
because that is a good predictor mmm of
what's going to happen next year and
then the one I'm really proud of yes
young people didn't even know smelling
salts but yeah people who are gonna
faint
yes the results are that is so true by
the way what did you find these well the
thing is I don't really sell smelling
salts anymore it's true so those are you
know these are illegal smelling salts
you got these on the street no she got
them from Thursday Night Football
I think how he had some them anymore
something I don't know like drugs yeah
or something but you get the point
I get the point now this is great that's
a good I'm adding a mouth guard because
it might be the only thing left after
2020 you know cuz it's gonna be a fight
grocery I'm gonna put that in there and
it tastes funny
when I played Pop Warner football or
whatever but yeah this should come get
it and clean it yeah we'll need a new
one this one will be used for some kind
of criminal investigation oh good
question so we're gonna put it in a
place where no one ever goes to the Fox
News gym my kid but it'll be placed in a
locker at the Fox News gym with its own
personal trainer and then we'll open it
no questions do we open it oh my god the
night of the doing Tuesday or do we wait
till Wednesday
alright that's what we'll do I mean
every one a year yeah yeah we all have
to be on oh that'll be the funniest
thing if like some of us aren't here
anymore yeah
you might not be here wait did you put
the mouthguard oh yeah you did might
even put the mouth guard in you're
telling me not to because you want to
put in a new one because I put in my
mouth all right groovy
well that was funny go there you go my
gamble for my own we'll get you another
gavel yeah yes yes I gather just
anywhere we get her a wooden one yeah
yeah well I broke it when I was on the
village it broken on some guys they were
too far from me okay all right